who's stripping down who got stabbed and
sorry black hood but new phone who dis
all that and so much more on this week
Sweetwater secrets hey vixens
I'm Leon Aguilera your serpent repping
host for the week and this is the
Sweetwater Secrets after-show for
episode 204 chapter 17 the town that
dreaded sundown
so these spoiler is tough spoilers are
headed your way
please enlighten me all right guys now
whether you're from the north side or
the south side we can all agree on one
thing
Betty's ponytail is iconic and beyond
reproach yes this week I'm chatting all
about Archie's testosterone-filled
antics dishing out some seriously
vicious hisses and hearing from Camilla
Mendez about her black hood theories but
first it's time to kick it all off with
the biggest headlines in the blue and
gold breakdown first up the old Betty
can't come to the phone right now why
cuz she's traumatized that's right the
episode ended with black hood calling
Betty from a blocked number augs and
he's definitely got a weird obsession
with our blonde beauty we can't tell
anyone about it now earlier in the
episode the black had sent Betty a
cipher and a letter explaining he was
inspired by Betty's Jubilee speech and
that he's doing all this crazy killing
for her he's a psychopath yikes you know
I still think the Cooper's are involved
with this black hood mess especially
Betty's mysterious maa brothers so we'll
have to see next up when the serpent
strike they draw blood that's right if
they flow on beat down between the
Southside serpents and the North Side
Bulldogs and was all thanks to Archie is
beyond intense obsession with finding
and killing the black hood now during
the brawl a serpent stabbed Dilton doily
in the leg
but if we're being honest I didn't feel
too bad for him I mean it did but we all
know that Dilton is a drama loving
adrenaline junkie and maybe this injury
when we can think twice before he starts
passing out deadly weapons like their
candy again moving on you know chapter
17 was filled with plenty of heated
moments but the hottest one definitely
belongs to Archie and Veronica now we
were treated to quite a few of Archie's
smooches and this week but their
rendezvous and Archie's bedroom tops
this week's seven seconds in heaven yes
I am all for Archie abs shots and oh is
that a gun in your pocket
Archie or are you just happy to see
Veronica
just kidding we all know that Archie
threw that gun and Sweetwater River so
let's keep going with this week's hisses
and kisses all right guys now bear with
me because the hisses are in full force
this week so let's rapid fire through
them now first up hisses - no Cheryl or
Josie and not enough Reggie in this
week's hour I need more hisses - hiram
again for being so shady and trying to
act like he didn't plant the seed for
the red circle in Archie's brain you
totally did
also when was it decided that Veronica
just waltz right into her arms
mysterious study wasn't that completely
forbidden last week can you let us know
when that changes so much chaos and
confusion all right next I'm sending the
biggest hist straight to Archie for
syncing out trouble and being borderline
psychotic about this black hood
obsession now I understand that you're
mad and frustrated archiekins but please
calm down
and it can't just be you against an
armed madmen and my last kiss is - tawny
topaz is this about Betty's ponytail but
major kisses - Kevin's epic clap back
Betty's ponytail is iconic and beyond
reproach you better watch yourself miss
Toni topes I see you trying to slither
your way in between buddy and jugheads
relationship here we go with the sea
again as for kisses I'm sending this one
straight to Alice Cooper's drama queen
behavior rock that crown girl and to
Veronica for showing that ladies get
things done it's adorable when you
underestimate me lastly here's a kiss to
this perfect Betty Cooper description
courtesy of Jughead Betty Cooper like
Nancy Drew Meets Girl with the Dragon
Tattoo for days all right guys now I'm a
little out of breath but the show must
go on here we go now I don't know about
you guys but I really loved seeing
Veronica take it upon herself to be
there for Archie and get involved in
this quest for the black hood now when I
caught up with Camilla Mendez on set she
told me she's been playing detective
both on and off screen at this point I
believe that you know do you know the
identity of who's under the hood I don't
don't know okay what do you think do you
have any fear and maybe I do no I think
I do okay but I'm not entirely sure how
is I don't trust I don't trust the
script sometimes you know I'm like I
feel like they want me to believe it's
this person but I think it's somebody
else how is this hooded figure gonna be
throwing the town for a loop I feel like
you're freaking out yeah everyone's
freaking out because somehow everyone's
involved and that's a really special
thing about season two is that we're all
taking part in breaking down the mystery
and I think there's also an episode
where Archie gets to kind of take over
bug head and be the black head of the
episode and be the detectives which is
fun um yeah the black hood is making
everybody go to a dark place and from
what I know about next week's episode
which is a lot it's only gonna get
darker well guys that does it for this
week Sweetwater after-show now check
back next time for the preview show for
episode 205 chapter 18 when a stranger
calls and here's a fun little tip for
you a lot of you guys have been tweeting
me and commenting asking how you guys
can know when a new episode of
Sweetwater secrets is up well if you're
watching this on the YouTube app which I
think you are click the link in my
description below it'll take you to the
Sweetwater secrets series page and
you'll see a little bell ring
Bell aka push it and you'll be
automatically notified when a brand new
episode of Sweetwater secrets is posted
to et's YouTube channel yay now as
always hit the comments and tell me your
top hisses and kisses of the week or you
can always tweet me all of your
Riverdale thoughts anytime you want now
thank you so much for watching river
babes a million kisses to you and I'll
see you next time for more Sweetwater
secrets
[Music]
you